voici le face à face du trésor avec
cette question la corse est elle raciste
et le nationalisme corse peut-il être
jugé responsable de la montée du racisme
en corse face à face dans un instant
maurice szafran qui est directeur de
publication du magazine marianne dont
jouit safran en jour et françois
sargentini qui est porte-parole d'
independence a corsica nacion n'hésitez
pas à nous faire connaître votre avis
par sms aux 5 15 15 ou par internet via
france 2 point fr on rappelle les
événements de ce week-end tout de même
vendredi un gérants de stations services
d'ajaccio d'origine marocaine assassiné
samedi la voiture d'un fonctionnaire du
consulat du maroc à bastia victime d'un
attentat est le même jour à corte près
de 500 personnes qui se sont rassemblées
pour débattre de la xénophobie dans
l'île avant le débat l'enquète de yann
front t il accepte de témoigner mais ne
veut pas être reconnu aujourd'hui ce
père de famille d'origine marocaine
installée depuis 45 ans en corse ne
supporte plus le climat ambiant
d'ailleurs il songe à quitter l'île
définitivement on est mal à l'aise
voilà on est mal dans sa peau
on sent pas chez soi on se passait choix
on n'est pas considéré pour comme on est
tous les courts métrages et on ne
connaît pas des humains sur sur la seule
sur cette terre une situation qui se
dégrade
il n'y a qu'à voir ses murs tagués à la
va vite pour le comprendre depuis
plusieurs mois les slogans hostiles se
sont multipliées arabi fera islam fort à
arhab islam dehors
en mars dernier une bataille rangée a
même opposé pendant plusieurs heures des
jeunes à d'autres jeunes d'origine
maghrébine dans les ruelles de bastia
et que dire de ces maisons plastique est
leur seul tort appartenir à des
propriétaires algériens tunisiens ou
marocains
plus grave encore la semaine dernière le
gérant marocains de cette station
service a été abattu de deux balles dans
la tête
les enquêteurs ne privilégient aucune
piste mais n'exclut pas un crime raciste
en corse les violences anti maghrébine
se banalise à la sortie des lycées
certains jeunes n'hésitent plus à
assumer leur xénophobie avec détachement
non mais pour moi de 60 et les personnes
d'origine maghrébine ne sont pas forts
c'est sûr ils peuvent être là depuis les
amis ne sont pas ces personnels quoi je
peux pas va pour la corse peut pas les
voir
un discours et des actes fruit d'une
minorité très visible mais une crise de
conscience semble être en marche ce
week-end à corte un rassemblement
antiraciste a réuni plus de 500
personnes anonymes hommes politiques
tous ont affiché leur désir de voir une
corse plus tolérante donc face à face
maurice szafran du magazine marianne et
françois sargentini pour parler
d'indépendance a corsica nacion je me
tourne vers vous monsieur sargentini on
ne se sent pas chez soi en corse disait
ce marocain au village au visage
dissimulé au tout début du du reportage
et puis cette jeune fille qui dit je
peux pas les voir
est-ce que vous en tant que leader
nationaliste vous vous sentez concerné
et vous ne reconnaissez pas que
peut-être vous avez servi de carburant
c'est vrai c'est triste ce qu'on vient
d'entendre mais je crois qu'il faut
quand même dire une chose je pense pas
que le peuple qu'on se soit pas plus
raciste que les autres peuples de la
terre
il est évident qu'en corse et une
situation complexe une situation
difficile depuis de nombreuses années et
je crois que il faut que tout le monde
ne sert-elle pour régler cette situation
mais ce que je veux affirmer ici c'est
que la conception que nous avons élus du
peuple corse est une conception ouverte
c'est un peuple corse qui est bien sûr
composé des causes d'origine mais bien
sûr des causes d'adoption c'est à dire
toutes les personnes qui arrivent en
corse et qui veut lui vendre ce qu'ils
veulent faire leur vie en cause ce qui
se passe là que le moscow que notre
position est claire c'est une
condamnation claire et ferme de tous les
actes racistes et de tous les
débordements de toutes les
communications racistes qui ont eu lieu
ces gens là ne peuvent pas se réclamer
de la vie du peuple corse
bon il s'apprend oui mais france
argentine il ya quand même eu quelques
petits problèmes qui se pose c'est que
évidemment on ne peut pas vous accuser
d'être raciste et anti musulman et je
serai le dernier à le faire simplement
l'idéologie que vous
véhicule est maintenant depuis des
années comme l'a dit chris holmes
enghelab donne du carburant aux racistes
encore la meilleure offre
c'est ce qui s'est passé cette nuit qui
sans doute autrement plus graves que
cette nuit il y a eu une négociation
entre la direction de la société
nationale corse méditerranée et le
syndicat des travailleurs corses et en
france en 2004 on peut lire dans la
presse française et corse matin très
tranquillement sans que ça provoque le
moins de problèmes
je cite la direction de la sncm a
accordé ouvrez grand vos oreilles s'il
vous plaît à accorder des conditions
d'embauché tenons compte de l'origine
des salariés en france donc on va
privilégier l'écart par rapport aux
marseillais ça s'excite absolument
invraisemblable bien sûr qu'il y a des
problèmes spécifiques à ceux qui
travaillent en corse mais que en france
aujourd'hui contre les syndicats
français contre les cinq gars français
on puisse faire des des embauches qui
tiennent compte des origines ethniques
des salariés c'est absolument graves
scandales et c'est une mauvaise
interprétation je crois que ce qui est
en train de passer
elle veut soutenir tout le monde qui la
sncm compagnie nationale qui assure et
d'amflora tiers sur son service sur la
corse fait 70% de son chiffre d'affaires
sur la corse par rapport aux embauches
14 % des embauches sont faites en corse
et en déséquilibre qui est anormal mais
ce que nous voulons c'est que leur
nourrit l'autre de la partie
il faut partager ce que nous voulons il
faut que demain lorsque les airs jazz
lorsque le savoir-faire est en corse il
faut l'utiliser encore si nous sommes en
fait en existe répondait à des questions
le prendre agne répondait aux questions
simples répondait à des questions
simples
est ce que aujourd'hui pour être corse
en corse
ça dépend du droit du sol du droit du
sol et des longues ces questions clefs
du to fall et le droit du sol pas du
tout je crois que toute personne qui
arrive en corse et qui veut devenir
cance elana la possibilité je crois pas
misogyne ou de vermine quelles que
soient ses jours
si ce n'est justement le problème les
critères de la république la question
fondamentale l'ascendant mental vous
savez que nous sommes dans une situation
conflictuelle avec la france depuis plus
de trente ans il ya une question
fondamentale qui est posée c'est celle
du peuple corse communauté de droit sur
sa terre nous sommes pour un peuple
corse
ouvert à toutes les personnes qui
veulent nous rejoindre un confrère du
tout mais si vous acceptez idée qu
éventuellement une certaine ambiguïté de
votre part non et non c'est non dit et
je crois que vous êtes anti racistes
vous même a entraîné des gens sur la
mauvaise pente
ce qui nous importe c'est le droit des
peuples ce n'est que ceux qui portent
notre mutuelle des peuples
vous pensez nous avons des relations
internationales avec des martiniquais et
des guadeloupéens se lancer scianna
qu'encana si vous pensiez un seul
instant que ces geôles entretiennent des
relations avec nous si nous étions
raciste si nous étions catalogue raciste
il des fêtes c'est sako simon se
présenter in et panenza que vous
représentez et d'avis de l'avis général
des spécialistes du mouvement corse la
vitrine légale du flnc union des
combattants
vous savez comme moi que je sais pas
vraiment à 100 ce donjon des groupes
ouvertement raciste donjon dont j'ai
dont je peux vous citer les noms ont été
intégrés dans le flnc union des
combattants et vous n'avez absolument
rien dit content alors que ce sont des
groupes qui ont fait ça pour des
attentats contre la grèce asus vous le
savez alors sur cette question sur cette
question précise
je crois effectivement il ya des groupes
qui ont été intégrés mais je crois que
la communication du fln sont aussi été
clair parce que je m'attendais à cette
question le flnc a fait arrêter cette
organisation et je crois que c'est quand
même essentiel je crois que c'est quand
même essentiel d'arrêter des gens qui
sont dans la dérive par contre ce que je
veux rajouter c'est qu'effectivement
cette méthode qui était employée n'était
peut-être pas la bonne aussi je crois
qu'il n'y a qu'une solution pour
combattre le racisme c'est se dresser
face à lui c'est de le combattre c'est
de le marginaliser ces de l'endiguer
parce que je vais vous dire une chose
qui se passe est contraire aux intérêts
du peuple corse
nous n'avons qu'à l'intérêt a sombré
dans un dans une dérive raciste parce
que ce que nous voulons nous pour demain
c'est une course ouverte sur le monde
sur la méditerranée un peu plus qu'aux
ouvert avec tous ceux qui voudront le
vent
ghannouchi il faudra qu'au delà de la
dénonciation traditionnelle du ministère
de l'intérieur les chiffres sont c'est
l'objet de la région ce n'est pas vrai
les chiffres ils sont pas plus où le
bébé né en 1980 sur les 92 faits les
plus graves de racisme en france en 2003
56 en corse selon les journaux comme
sienne ou non de la commission nationale
des droits de l'homme merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté et animer ce débat